and finally new rule grow a pair
last week the Democrats made a terrible
decision when they announced that they
had turned down Fox News's offer to host
one of their twenty20 primary debates
saying Fox was nothing more than
propaganda okay so why not go on Fox
News and tell them that you want to be
in the big you want to be in the big
leagues but you refuse to ever play in a
way game you know like the questions
that Fox News might ask so you're
deciding to not take any questions at
all
how very trump of you this is a this is
a fundamental problem with the
Democratic Party
they look weak running from a fight when
they should be in there throwing punches
Republicans never shy away from coming
on this show and they come with a smile
on their face despite knowing that the
only people in the crowd cheering them
on are the 3 campaign aides they brought
with them
[Laughter]
[Applause]
the ones who eat all the food in the
green the audience is against them and
they don't care because it's an
opportunity to expose people to your
side of the story so what if they're
groans groans won't kill you political
TV is full of groans and I rolls and
pouting and worst of all
Tucker face you want to get Tucker face
I used to think the reason I never saw a
prominent Democrats on fox news was they
weren't invited I thought they were
banned from appearing on the network
like I am but no they're invited they
just don't go well I shouldn't say all
here's a list of prominent Democrats who
do frequently go on Fox News Congressman
Eric's wall well that's it that's the
list last week's well well tweeted I've
been on nearly every Fox show I don't go
on because I accept the views of their
hosts but because I respect that some of
their viewers are open-minded exactly
19% of all voters Democrat and
Republican said Fox News was their main
source of campaign news that's ahead of
every other source it's more than ABC
CBS and NBC combined only three percent
of voters said their main source was the
New York Times and they were lying look
we all know Fox News sucks
it's ruined Facebook and Thanksgiving
and turned your grandpa into a dick
[Applause]
he's crabby now and he only leaves the
house once every four years but
unfortunately it's to vote you have to
get inside the bubble you call yourself
the resistance then fight behind enemy
lines that's what a resistance does
that's it ever it's been blowing up a
tank and tweeting about it get out of
your echo chamber and infiltrate there's
I noticed that the new tradition for
Democrats who've just announced they're
running is to go on Rachel Maddow
spoiler alert you already have her vote
she's Democrats they're like Mormons if
mormons only proselytized in utah but
but mormon he's for a hundred years have
gone all over the world with one goal to
spread their faith to people who don't
want it
to spread it to savages with their own
weird gods like the French but that's
how you build a brand look at Samoa 15
percent of it is Mormon do they look
Mormon was it an easy sell when the guys
with white shirts and clip-on ties
showed up you know President Kennedy
said we choose to go to the moon not
because it's easy but because it's hard
where's that kind of Democrat today so
what a fox news is fixed life is fixed
you want a fair shake go get a massage
with Robert Kraft
you